should you volunteer while searching for
a job let's find out
welcome back to another edition of
Udacity career tips my name is Martin
McGovern and this week we have a bit of
advice from a graduate of our full-stack
nanodegree program they say sometimes
when you least expected a job offer
comes along I volunteered at a coding
initiative for Refugees and turn this
experience into a permanent role the
organization offered me a remote
position paying a competitive salary and
at the same time I get to make a
difference in people's lives this grad
is sharing some great advice and is not
alone in their opinion that volunteering
is a great boost for your job search
according to a study from the
Corporation for National and Community
Service that tracked more than 70
thousand jobless people between 2002 and
2012 they found that those who had
volunteered had a 27% better chance of
finding a job than those who didn't so
if you're struggling in your search and
not quite sure what to do find an
organization in need and offer a helping
hand you'll build your skills meet
valuable contacts and fill your resume
with relevant charitable experience but
now I put the question back to you
have you ever volunteered and if so have
you ever seen any career gains come from
your volunteer work either intentional
or unintentional share your stories in
the comments and help other job seekers
who are looking to volunteer come up
with some ideas to get out there and
help people
thank you so much for watching if you
know anyone who's searching for a job
right now tag them and let them know
you're thinking about them we look
forward to bringing you many more videos
like this in the future and wish you the
best of luck in your job search